[Music]
it's a nice place to shoot videos I
think we do agree this you know dragon
boats and people yelling and stuff but
it's pretty I want to talk about getting
in case anybody stuck with the backwards
to beat leave I want to get you unstuck
because if long as you do each step you
can definitely get through this
so grab your pork face this way with me
step number one is you need to practice
what each hand is going to do or each
ploys going to do so say we're gonna
start with this one crossing to the left
shoulder first left goes under left
shoulder left goes under left shoulder
left goes under this is seed backward to
beat weave with the left play under in
the right put on top you'll also learn
it the other way with the right put
under and the elect play on top but
we're gonna start with the left foot
under so practice the parts of course
right boys gonna be on top so just
practice the right play going over the
left arm and ever make sure don't stand
there stiff make sure figure out how to
let your whole body move with it your
body's following the play that's gonna
make this easier in the long run and
then practice your left poi going under
your right and for the right if I reach
over here it's much easier to go under
each time I reach over to go under
because if I hold it out here it's gonna
be tough to get under it right so I make
it easy on myself I reach over and I go
under right goes over left crosses under
us see that big ball it's like I reach
towards science world and cross under my
arm I reach across under you'll get it
don't worry
have you already know it by now but you
need to prep the motor skills so that
they fire the way you want them to so
once you've done that what we're gonna
do is we're gonna come back the same
time and just do this with me just cross
like that exactly I said imagine a
rainbow here you just fly along the
rainbow that's all along the rainbow
yeah easy and then you go along the
rainbow what you're gonna do is scoot
the left boy under the right just like
this you can hold this POI if it didn't
work
the hands go together and the left play
goes under the right arm and really go
under like make it really clear you go
you want to see that cross if you're not
seeing that cross it's not gonna work so
you go along the rainbow and cross and I
can really see the cross my arms from
the top cross under yeah over cross
under and when I do two points the same
thing along the rheine roll and I make
the cross so I can really see that in my
arms along the rainbow make the crust
along the rainbow make the cross and you
can do it a few times in a row along the
rainbow cross and then together and
cross and what's happening the poi are
flying same time at the rainbow and then
there's split time as I cross and if you
do it a few times in a row you'll
quickly click and you'll let starts
again left starts again let and then go
oh and suddenly it's gonna click and
you're big oh I see it's like this this
trick hey let's say you know once it's
working it'll suddenly be like you think
so same thing on the other side you're
going to do all the same steps but on
the other side it's going to be the
right under the left and you'll have to
maybe practice each step again the right
crossing under the left arm until that
sort of fired up in your motor skills
and the left crossing over the right arm
until that's all prepped and ready to go
in your motor skills and then you're
gonna go along a rainbow and cut the
right under along the rainbow and under
along the rainbow and under along the
rainbow under and boom boom boom boom
boom boom and now they're going along
the rainbow split time I'm under the
split time and under and split time and
under same thing you need to see that
cross is what happens is people when
doesn't work they go like this and they
let the left lead back that means your
arms stayed parallel and it'll never
work like that so the trick is really
it's only gonna work if you go kaboom
and you make x marks the spot with your
arms as soon as you get that then you've
got it I can be at your wrists your
elbows but you really need to see the
cross and then that's going to click
you'll be like oh it was I've still got
this maybe on this side we got on this
side and then I got a new set and the
next thing you know you're the preview
and then you'll behind window and it's
gonna be all the things
[Music]